in this video we'll talk about the
chronic granulomatous disease this is a
high yield video for USMLE step one
chronic granulomatous disease is a
disease where the function of neutrophil
is compromised neutrophil is a key
immune cell type that engulfs
pathogen-like bacteria when they invade
our body but this function of the
neutrophil is generally compromised in
this disease let us learn why this is
compromised in cgd or chronic
granulomatous disease there is a
hereditary reason for which the
neutrophils are unable to destroy the
ingested pathogen
generally neutrophil engulfs the
pathogen and they kill the pathogen with
the help of a process known as
respiratory burst
in the process of respiratory burst
these uh
phagosomes secrete specific reactive
oxygen species and these reactive oxygen
species is generated inside the
neutrophil with the help of an enzyme
known as nadph oxidase obviously it's an
enzyme and it is encoded by a gene in
chronic granulomatous disease this Gene
is mutated giving rise to a faulty
product that means the conversion of
oxygen into superoxide radical doesn't
happen in this case
that is why
the neutrophil is unable to neutralize
the pathogen or kill the pathogen with
the help of reactive oxygen species
when genetics is concerned there are two
types of cjt one is x-linked cjd another
is autosomal recessive cgt in x-link cjd
there is 50 chance that males would be
affected
and the 50 chance is also there that the
female would be carrier the females are
generally not affected in that case
then in autosomal recessive cjd the
chances are even lower the chance of
upper infant getting affected is 25
percent when both their periods are
actually carrier
let's talk about the pathology of cjd
now in order to understand the pathology
we have to first understand the cellular
phenomena of respiratory burst I have a
little video on that but in short oxygen
is converted into superoxide radical
with the help of nadph oxidase
and in this process nadph is oxidized
into nadpa nadp
then superoxide dismutus convert this
into H2O2 and H2O2 further gets
converted with the help of
myeloperoxidase into hocl radical
H2O2 can also be neutralized into water
with the help of enzyme catalase now
there are series of other enzymes which
are helping in this process like
glutathione reductase and many other
enzymes now the key thing that get
abrogated in cjd is the nadph oxidase
but before that try to understand that
all these oxidative species can possibly
kill the bacteria but how
so Ross can change many aspects of
bacterial physiology it can first
damage the protein it can also lead to
lipid peroxidation
that lead to a disorderedness of the
membrane it damages the lipid and that
can create a leak in the membrane it can
also create DNA damage so if the
bacterial DNA is damaged the bacteria
would eventually die so this is how Ross
can take a key role in killing the
bacteria
but the neutrophils ability to create
oxidative burst is compromised in
chronic granulomatous disease due to
that mutation in nadph oxidase
now since superoxide radical is not
produced
these but these these neutrophils can
possibly engulf the bacteria but they
cannot destroy it
that is why there are
granuloma formation which are nothing
but clums of neutrophils macrophages and
other phagocytotic cell with the
bacteria it's it's they can kind of
trying to entrap their bacteria but fail
to
kill them efficiently that is why
granuloma forms in this disease that's
why it is known as chronic granulomatous
disease
patients are at high risk of infection
when they are infected by Catalyst
positive bacteria okay when you don't
have superoxide radical the neutrophil
would try to neutralize with hydrogen
peroxide and it would try to create that
hocl radical but when H2O2 or peroxide
radical is neutralized with the help of
catalyst enzyme by these bacteria or
fungus then neutrophil has no reactive
oxygen species left
that is why
the patients are basically
infected by staphylococcus aureus
aspergillus or by candida symptoms might
include persistent fever abscess
pneumonia skin infection and
gastrointestinal issues
several other complications can also
arise in cjd these complications include
obstructive europathology
hepatosplinomegaly and inflammatory
bowel disease-like symptoms
let's talk about the diagnosis of cjd
the diagnosis of cjt involves different
functional testing one of the simplest
one is Nitro blue tetrazolium dye
reduction test so in that case basically
normal sample in normal sample the Ross
would convert NBT into form as an
product that means a bluish color
substance
so in the sample the the overall blood
cells are intubated with this particular
dye NBT which is light yellowish in
color and the formation product is
bluish in color
but when the ability of neutrophils are
compromised in terms of production of
Ross then a negative finding would be
observed that means incubated leukocytes
fail to turn the plate in a bluish color
and the yellow color retains that means
not enough Ross was produced by the
neutrophil at the first place
similar principles can be applied in
case of dihydrodamin test in this case
the ability of neutrophils superoxide
production is measured and this is
measured with a high throughput flow
cytometry in this case
unstimulated neutrophil and uh there is
a treatment which is called PMA
treatment is used and in PMA treatment
that there should be a shift in these
Pro facts profile
now when this shift doesn't happen that
means there is a problem with the
neutrophils ability to form the
superoxide reticle
let's talk about the treatment of cjd
cjd treatment has to be done with the
help of antibiotics and antifungal so
there is no perfect treatment so the
clinical symptoms has to be kind of
managed and sometimes people might think
of like a crispr-based therapies which
are not common in this case but
eventually down the line one might have
a solution with the help of specific
genomic genomic editing like a
treatment
so I hope this was useful and you can
get more notes and flashcards in my
Facebook page you can also follow us in
Instagram page all the links are
provided in the description you can
support our Channel using super thanks
you can also pay using PayPal paytm or
UPI so subscribe to our Channel get
touch with get in touch with us with all
the social media links provided see you
in next video
foreign
[Music]